[Musique]
quand j'étais petit je rêvais de
transformer cette boule en
colombe merci monieur
dam comment je vais faire pour m'occuper
de Lison si on travaille tous les soirs
tu fas comme tous les parents seuls qui
boss tu dem à JAC je suis sera ravi de
t'aider grandparents qui s'occupent de
leurs petits enfants c'est courant je
CIS je préfère encore noun si JEE ton je
Fass des snap avec
lui le bébé c'est laavenie on peut lui
mettre une
litière j'ai un vrai savoir-faire avec
les enfants qu'est-ce qui se passe ça
couche encore débordé attention Jacques
là c'est quoi ça
estaimes pas le chocolat on l' bien eu
ton papa si tu veux je peux rester ici
ou ça pour m'occuper de la
petite tu as faim tu as soif tu envie de
faire caca je sais pas je su crevé moi
en ce moment
je suis pas prêt pour tout ça façon j'ai
vraiment envie de voir personne je viens
de perdre la mère de ma fille alors vous
voyez je VO très
[Musique]
bien alors elle propose une grande
tournée en province c'est quoi ton idée
pour lon qu'elle reste ici avec son
grand-père tu vas laisser ta fille tout
ce temps tu risques ta vie tous les
soirs imagine t'arrive un truc si tu es
prêt à faire Deisel je t'en prie ce sera
sans moi c'est pour qui le cadeau c'est
pour
qui je suis pas à la
hauteur pas facile de se mettre à la
hauteur d'une petite
[Musique]
fille papa
prê